you've seen that there's chat GPT and
there's open AIS gpt3 what's your
opinion of them are you excited by them
are you surprised by them
I'm excited that those tools become
available but I'm also kind of worried
that people are too enthusiastic about
them
and they for me the problem is that
they're basically what somebody called
parrots right they're parrots that have
heard a lot of language being spoken
everything that was ever written
and they are very good at repeating
putting together those sentences and
words together
but there is no really under no real
understanding underneath those systems
cannot tell us
why they think
the these things that they say are true
they basically repeating the words that
have been written somewhere and
rearranging
to be fair most people when they're
putting out something that's creative
they're just repeating what they've seen
and they're mixing it up and they
believe it to be absolutely new and also
just so you know there is something
creative about mixing up and then
presenting it and furthermore most
people maybe even all of us we don't
know the motivations like we'll
confabulate some reason for why we
created so and so like that's why the
whole field of psychoanalysis came about
because we don't know why we do what we
do we make up some reason so why does it
matter that the computer doesn't know
why it does what it's doing and that
it's quote unquote
repeating while mixing let's say mixing
what's old
I don't think it matters if you're
interested in a computer producing art
like writing a song or painting a
picture
but it doesn't matter if you rely on the
computer to tell you what the truth is
right
because if you don't if somebody cannot
explain to you why they believe
something is true
then how can you trust them
these are deep questions
so yeah what I find remarkable is that
you can just even a simple program
asking it to code this in Python code
something that does this in Python code
something that does this in Auto hotkey
or whatever it may be and it does it or
does it 90 the way there who the heck I
didn't think that that would be possible
for quite some time there's something
truthful about that in the sense that it
works like you can actually test if the
code works so that's a test of Truth
more so than a statement are you happy
about that or you feel like even that
old technology that could have been done
five years ago or
so well the program programming is a bit
different story right because
you can actually test programs right
so if some if you ask
whether it's a human or it's a bot to
write a program you can you provide a
specification then you can go through
the testing the test procedure and find
out if that program really does what it
does right so we don't actually have to
trust
the pro the trust anything we can just
test it right but if we don't if we die
if if we don't have time to test it then
I would be wondering whether it's a good
idea to depend on such a program